le jardin de l'état a accueilli son
archet spécial fête des mères l'ambition
pour le département est de faire
découvrir ou redécouvrir aux visiteurs
des produits péi de qualité des fruits
elle est une simple et goûteuse quelques
gourmandises et autres créations
originales les nombreux promeneurs et
exposants ont su apprécier ce moment ça
a permet aux gens de voir ce qu'on fait
quand ils savent déjà par le biais du
conseil départemental mais ça l'est
permet aussi de voir nos produits d et
surtout de les acheter les artisans pays
dans ce tour intéressant un petit
clavier salle baudin villes d'asie
j'aime cette ambiance conviviale c'est
très agréable
moi je me détends ici aujourd'hui on a
ramené un petit peu les boules et
véritable goût de notre part témoigne
qu'une idée à sion peut dire ça persiste
depuis ce matin je suis arrivé les gens
même à 8 heures moi ça manque mais ça
vous savez au bandeau sa part comme
d'équipé et donc moi c'est que du
bonheur commandes dès que j'ai vu j'ai
eu envie de l'acheter
il est bien fait et je pourrais mettre
mon téléphone dedans et à la proche de
la fête des mères les idées cadeaux ne
manquez pas les incontournables plantes
et fleurs des senteurs délicates ou même
un petit objet à fabriquer soi-même à
l'atelier bois de goyavier le
département a mis en place aujourd'hui
le thème
voyager pour la fête des mères qui aura
lieu dimanche
donc un petit objet comme ça pour le
moment la moselle beaucoup la mort
mettre en valeur des producteurs et
artisans locaux participer à l'économie
locale selon les intérêts majeurs pour
le département rendez vous en août pour
le prochain marché pays au jardin de
l'état et pour les plus impatients tous
les deuxièmes samedis du mois à l'espace
ray de l'est en attendant joaillier
seraient des maires je t'aime maman tout
mon coeur
[Musique]